I'm going to Vietnam and I'm
bringing 'em beer!
(All) Yeah!
♪♪
Rick:
Are you ready?
What are we doing?
We're gonna run for our lives.
(Artillery fire)
We're halfway home.
Halfway?!
(Ding)
I'm Chickie Donohue, and I am
not supposed to be in Vietnam.
♪♪
Hey, get your ass out of
bed, you lazy bum.
Mr. Donohue:
Look at you, sleeping your life
away.
♪♪
Red:
Look at these scumbags.
(Protest chants)
Hey! You're embarrassing
yourself, and you're
embarrassing your family.
Do these protesters not know
that our soldiers see them on
TV.
I'd like to go over to Vietnam.
The Colonel:
Track down all the boys in the
neighborhood and
give 'em a beer.
I could do that.
Do what?
Bring 'em beer.
He's not serious, he's hammered.
Look at him.
The man is stone sober.
That's his fifth beer, maybe,
tops.
I'm going to Vietnam, and I'm
bringing 'em beer!
(All)
Yeah!
♪♪
Hey chief, no chance you have a
ship going to Vietnam?
1700 hours.
Tonight?
♪♪
Chickie:
It's not gonna be easy.
But I'm gonna show them that
this country is still behind them.
You're gonna get yourself killed
over there.
It's like you said, everyone's
doing something.
I'm doing nothing.
♪One morning I woke up♪
Arthur Coates:
Smuggling beer into a war-zone,
it's not the smartest thing I've
ever heard of.
It's certainly not the worst
either.
♪A new day, a new way♪
What if you start up here with
Collins...
Aaah!
-Haha!
Just came to deliver a sudsy
thank you card.
Kevin:
...and then, if you're still
alive...
(Honking)
(Traffic)
You American?
New York!
Chickie:
Thanks a lot.
Kevin:
...you can hustle down to
Duggan.
Ta-da.
Chickie?
I brought you beer.
♪♪
You shouldn't be here.
Rick:
You think this is funny?
(Shoots-off flare)
Chickie:
I'm not doing this for laughs,
I'm doing it for all you guys.
♪♪
Whoa-whoa!
Hey!
Come on, time to go.
Is it over?
Yeah, you're dead.
♪Carry on♪
Rick:
You don't get it, do you, Chick.
This isn't a John Wayne movie
Rick:
where you know who the good guys
are
Rick:
and you know who the bad guys
are.
♪Love is coming♪
I didn't come all this way
just to quit.
Arthur Coates:
Somebody's gotta be here to see
what's going on.
♪♪
Arthur Coates:
I want the truth told...
♪♪
...for them.
Arthur Coates:
They're just kids.
You're gonna find out it's a lot
harder to get out of a war than
it is to get into one.
Chickie:
I'm trying to show them that
somebody back home is still behind them.
♪♪
Rick:
You got a good heart, Chickie.
It's your brain I'm worried
about.
♪♪
♪Carry on♪
Who's this hand-job?
My next-door neighbor.
He brought me a beer.
♪♪
Hey.